Yeah.
Bonjour tout le monde et bienvenu à la Jeudi
après midi just avant vendredi podcast et lundi matin et
je just checking in sur vous.
What's up mother fuckers bonjour,
uh,
je m'appelle Guillaume et je suis dans le Paris and I'm a little buzzed.
I'm not gonna lie to you.
I had a couple of does seize soixante quatre s'il vous plaît oui monsieur.
Yeah.
Um,
what the fuck do you say afterwards and they come back,
uh,
um,
la même chose,
uh,
monsieur or whatever the fuck,
I don't know.
You want to use one of my completely shit faced right now is because I have a
kid.
That's another good reason for becoming a parent.
It's not because you want to raise a good person and experience a level of love
that you've never felt before.
It's really because you failed in your own attempts at sobriety and you're too
much of a loner and your two antisocial to ever go to Aa.
That's the time to have long fall to have a kid,
a baby,
right.
Way,
a way that media,
ah,
yeah.
That way you said in the wig,
you sound like some dumb tourist,
right?
Yes.
If it's funny over here is I've been just fucking torturing these people with my
French and I don't give a fuck when they start speaking English back to me.
I don't switch you over.
I'm going to fucking sit there and search for the word and you're going to sit
there and fucking take it.
Like you have the biggest fucking more on ever sitting across from you on the
$10,000 pyramid and the clock's ticking and you ain't went in mayard baby.
MMM.
I fucking love it over here.
I love the people.
I love the food.
I,
I could literally lose the next 20 years of my life staying over here pretending
that I'm an intellectual.
There's just something about getting shit faced in a cafe.
You just don't feel like,
you know,
we don't do it right in America where they,
they make it go inside where it's all dark and you got a hunch down and fucking,
it takes you like 20 minutes just for your eyes to adjust to see if does anybody
else in there,
right?
The person you've been hitting on is,
hey,
Mira,
her amen.
And Ressa.
Here comes pat.
Um,
out here they let you be a drunk in public.
You just sit there on the side of the new rule the street,
right?
And you fucking sit there with a sport coat on a little pocket square and you,
if you feel like you're reading,
I have not improved myself at all as a human being over here.
And I could not be having more fun.
I've eaten a fucking bag at every God damn day.
Uh,
I've gone to know museums.
I went to the Notre Dam a way that went over there.
And finally I was just,
we went over that goal.
Let's take a fucking picture.
And what I love about my Klaff Mo proper fam is that,
uh,
she doesn't give a shit about that stuff either.
I told you that story when we went to [inaudible],
right?
And we did what everybody who doesn't give a fuck about art does.
We went in there and we were like,
hey,
fuck the other 900 million square feet of art.
Where is the
Mollys Mona Lisa.
Right.
And they told us where it was and we went in there and we like,
there it is little bit bigger than a stamp.
You good?
I'm good.
Let's get the fuck Outta here.
And that was it.
That's it.
We left thought,
oh gosh,
I don't know how we get out of there,
but we,
I don't remember the exact directions.
Okay.
But we've just fucking got out of there.
And,
uh,
you know,
when we were coming into town,
oh,
which I used to know that word.
Um,
I wish I could've taken a video if I was ever teaching a class on creativity.
Okay.
First of all,
who the fuck would ever have me teach anything?
And secondly,
where do I get off acting?
Like I'm creative.
I'm a curmudgeon and I'm good at criticizing shit.
All right?
However,
I'm going to criticize this.
There was like,
fucking,
I think I already talked about this.
We would passing in front of,
uh,
the Lou and,
they said stupid fucking glass pyramid that they made that I think a lot of
Parisian didn't like,
you know,
they don't like anything new.
Anything new is fucking,
you know,
I don't know.
I don't know what they call it.
A vulgar.
That's one of the best insults ever,
you know,
to describe something you just did and unless someone just said a bunch of f
bombs,
then it's,
it's whatever.
But if you'd like to make fun of somebody's shirt,
the design of it and described it as vulgar.
Um,
I dunno.
It's about as deep as it gets for someone who doesn't curse I think.
Right.
So it was a sport coat on stage,
right?
Standing up there
like Johnny Carson still hosting the tonight show and they're working on their
five minutes set.
I don't fucking know.
Anyways,
we would drive in.
You cut through
and at Blatt is a bunch of fucking tourists all standing up.
Having somebody else take the picture is they pretend to be like holding the top
of the pyramid.
I swear to God,
we drove by and it was like nine people all doing it at the same time,
you know?
And if I was ever a lip professor,
I would take a video of that and he'd go,
you see this shit right here?
If you want to be creating,
don't do that.
This is a difference between being inspired.
Yeah.
By seeing somebody doing something and then just going up and doing exactly what
the fuck doing.
Yeah.
It's still going to be a great picture.
But what's going to happen is that's going to be the fucking hacky thing that
you do,
right?
Until somebody switches it up.
And this is what kills me.
This is going to be one person that switches up what you do with yourself in the
foreground of that stupid fucking glass pyramid in front of that.
You move,
right?
And if it gets enough hits and Lolz and uh,
oh my God,
this is the greatest Instagram photo ever than everybody will do that.
You know?
I don't know.
Someone will plank on it.
If people remember that the fucking moment of creativity,
laying face down on something.
I'm not laying face down and not doing anything.
I'm planking,
oh Jesus.
Bill a couple of beers and you become even more [inaudible].
Huh?
Why don't you order a side order a templates here?
Um,
anyways,
I resent the fact that I have to still do these fucking things.
All right.
I'm on vacation.
Do you go to work when you're on vacation?
I don't think you'd do.
Um,
my relatives came out to that show when I was in England and they bought me a
bottle.
I don't know why,
but they have salted caramel.
Oh my God.
Coco vodka liquor
and um,
it's just been sitting here staring at me and I gotta be honest with you.
I'm just wondering,
I got to know what that hangover feels like.
It's like you have a watch one of those as far as hangovers go,
you ever watch a sounds like it's almost nap time.
You have a hit.
You ever watched one of those things?
I'm like,
what the,
the army ranger training or navy navy seal trading.
Yeah.
This is like the hang like you think you had a fucking hangover?
Like you'd think you're out there,
right?
You think you're working out doing your little crossfit Shit and run up down the
street while I sit there and fucking cafe getting hammered,
wearing my little sport coat.
You know,
like you're fucking showing me up.
Like I'm impressed with you and you think you're a bad ass.
Um,
then you watch that shit.
You watch what fucking army rangers and all those special force people,
right?
I mean,
just next level fucking be the two people that Matt Damon plays in a movie.
You know what I mean?
Not The people that get applause as they trudged through the airport in their
fatigues to go sit and do a cubicle to order grenades that they're never going
to throw.
These are the fucking people that a list movie stars play,
right?
Well,
this bottle here,
this is la.
I don't know if this is the fucking this hangover,
right?
You know what,
they,
when they lift up that fucking log,
those army ranges and there's like fucking 20 of them.
And then when somebody fucking falls over and pukes and they got to pick up
their own puke can take it outside the zone and then they're out.
And now there's 19 year and then he got to hold up his wake.
Whatever that fucking metaphor is.
Oh my God.
You know,
fast would be out of that pit.
Okay.
[inaudible] I like,
dude,
I need my back for the rest of my life.
Okay.
And I don't need the pressure of everybody else's defendant on me and I'm the
weak link in the chain.
I understand this.
I'm barely surviving standing out here in the fucking Sun.
Forget about going over there and picking up a fucking telephone pole with
fucking nine other people who,
who have the genetics of a fucking pit bull.
Okay.
I don't,
I'm a lapdog.
Okay.
I'm the kind of dog that could go on a plane before they had that bullshit where
you could say all this thing is like helping me emotionally.
Um,
I dunno.
I don't even want to talk about,
does that fill up enough time?
Fuck nine minutes.
This is like when I'm bombing on stage and I'm like,
Oh God,
I just got to end this set.
I've got to do a half hour.
It's gotta be like 28 minutes,
right.
Nine minutes
Hamata fucking material.
Um,
so anyways,
we are staying uh,
in the,
uh,
these what going I might say,
what the fuck we gotta be some Weirdo.
Somehow we'll find me.
Then I got to fucking sit there and answer questions about how to start a
podcast in Paris.
Excuse him.
Uh,
uh,
Mister Gamba is how you stay
only
Ellis D.
MMM.
Anyways,
plowing ahead.
So,
uh,
my condolence to my fellow Americans right now,
if you're not into baseball,
cause that's the only game in town baby.
And don't even talk to me about the w and NBA,
NBA.
I know it's much better.
The level of play is much better.
I understand that.
Okay.
But that's like a,
you know,
it's very rare.
UFC did it.
You have [inaudible] you have see dead it and they went.
Not only did they start after the big four or big three really,
and then hockey comes along,
but when you wait,
you wait until they had Seattle.
You wait till the ad Seattle and all this fucking rain drenched lumberjacks.
Okay?
Who are tired of all of those?
Fucking ridiculous Harry fucking muffs up there.
Have another thing that they can focus their attention on.
You wait till the NHL is going to start nipping at the heels of a,
I'm gonna say baseball.
I'm going to go with baseball.
All right?
They built a bunch of new stadiums.
The steroid era is over and it just sort of settling into like,
this is what we do.
You know,
if I were the owners in the MLB right now,
I would say,
all right,
we need some sort of synthetic fucking steroids.
All right?
We'll do it just like the pharmaceutical companies did with heroin.
Okay,
we'll make a synthetic version of steroids and we'll just sort of leak it into
a,
I dunno,
sunflower seeds and then all of a sudden all the fucking numbers are going to
start going up.
Right?
Yeah.
I mean,
didn't you like wrestling better when everyone was on roids?
if they just would just let them work a five day work week,
you know,
not work them into the ground.
What they fucking,
I mean,
writes a great,
aren't they at this point,
don't they have them like it?
Like the,
you know,
like weed,
you can have like the uh,
what do they call that thing there?
The little mister there,
you know,
little weed aroma thing.
You can buy the fuck.
Do you call that thing breathalyzer not on a breathalyzers for drinking and
driving bill.
Um,
you should have seen what the fucking breathalyzer it look like.
When I took it at the police station when I got busted for drinking driving
almost 30 fucking years ago.
It looks like a fucking,
like a bag pipe in a mixed with a Douche bag.
It's just giant rubber fucking hoes.
I blow into it,
I would just puffing up my cheeks.
Try not to blow into it.
Cause I knew,
I knew I had a big number.
I knew I had a number that even if I had a f Lee fucking Bailey,
I wasn't getting out of it.
You know,
might have to have a last name like Bush,
Kennedy,
one of those fucking royalty names,
one of those regal fucking names that everybody in England refuses to recognize
that not only are they on par with the royal family,
I would dare say that they're a little bit beyond were taken collars.
Um,
by the way,
I want to thank the country of Ireland.
All right,
but coming up with a fucking jumpers.
All right.
This thing has been the shit.
Late night in Paris,
walking around smoking a cigar,
you know,
with my stupid fucking Brian Johnson ACDC hat on.
I really look like the old man that I am and uh,
I'm enjoying it.
You know,
God,
I was thinking this morning,
laying in bed,
not being able to sleep.
I was thinking back to some shit when I was a kid and I was thinking like,
oh my God,
that's like 45 fucking years ago.
Okay,
45 years ago was 1973 now in 1973 if I ran into a 50 year old guy and he said I
was here 45 years ago,
what year would that be everybody?
That would be 1928 according to my couple of beers.
Math,
that's how fucking old I am now.
Like to a five year old kid right now.
1973 was what?
1928 was to meet when I was five years old.
Not that I really contemplated.
I used to think the 1950s were the olden days.
That's what really fucking kills me.
When I was five years old.
Second,
I could still could've son Elvis.
Yeah.
I think he wasn't even fat yet.
You know,
could have gone into Vegas and watch them treat me a lot.
Oh,
boo
crew.
Watch him sing that song for the 9,000 time that fucking week out in Vegas.
You know?
I think the mob killed him.
I really do.
He probably signed the colonel,
probably send him to some lifetime contract and then when he just got all fat
eating those peanut butter fucking banana sandwiches,
they are just like,
all right,
we've got to get rid of this guy.
Isn't that what happens in the mob?
Does anybody like die of old age?
I know you can die of a heart attack sitting around eating all that fucking,
you know,
was it linguine as,
that's the one that's bad for you,
right?
It's like a fucking butter base cream sauce.
Jesus Christ just sitting there slurping it up,
having to look at the door every two seconds and nobody comes in and wax Ya.
I've never understood it beyond the cars and the pinky rings in the great suits
in the fucking hottest women in the fucking town.
You know,
you can't sit down and eat a bowl of pasta without staring at the fucking door
every two seconds.
Is it really fucking worth it?
Maybe it is.
I Dunno.
You know,
at some point I should start taking college rather than just asking fucking
questions that float out into the fucking Urbis
15 minutes.
That's it.
Jesus.
I feel like I'm in fucking math class back in,
back in high school.
Oh my God.
Sine cosine.
Tangent.
Just fucking flunk me.
Yeah.
Is that so hard to do?
We really have to go to 180 days of this shit.
Keisha tell right from the beginning.
You don't do any scouting.
Um,
they didn't.
It was public schools and you know what?
It was all free.
It's all free or not now.
Not now.
Cause every fucking kid out there need to goddamn tablet and 15,000 other
fucking things.
Okay.
And public schools can't afford to do that anymore.
Now can they?
Oh,
they could.
They could if we weren't fighting fucking 3,500 fucking jerk offs without
uniforms that train on a fucking jungle gym acting like that.
Somehow going to overthrow this country.
Huh?
Despite the fact we've done battle with first world nations and beat their
asses.
Do you want to stand that this is the team that's not even in the fucking
league?
Yeah.
This is a friendly,
it was sitting there acting like this is going to go up against their fucking
record.
Unbelievable.
And meanwhile these poor fucking kids in America going to school right now and
we were not even decent enough with their own tax money to provide them tablets
that they can go onto to ignore this assignments and watch when watching free
online porn.
Okay.
That's why I'm actually thinking about sending my kid to public schools because
they can't afford any of that shit.
Right.
And then maybe my kid can,
can go,
you know,
actually have a childhood before,
some other fucking degenerate kid comes up and shows them God knows fucking what
on their phone or their tablet or the,
all of that shit.
You know what I mean?
I know I've talked about this shit before.
I know that I've said already on this podcast that I've talked about this shit
before.
I don't care if this is like,
I'm going down memory fucking lane.
All right.
Yeah.
This is my,
my,
I think this is my first podcast officially like pass the hangover of turning 50
I'm in my,
I'm in my fifties and let me tell you,
when you get your 50s you think you'd know shit.
What are you talking about?
You fucking little whippersnappers.
Okay.
I've been around the block for half a fucking century.
You how many times I've been around the sun?
MMM.
Without even noticing.
Somebody actually sent me that as a birthday thing.
Congratulations for like your 10000th trip around the fucking sun or something
like that.
I think it was like 10,000 right?
Isn't that how many times you go around the sun?
50 years.
I hope that's,
I hope I way over exaggerate just just for that person that knows the answer so
they can feel better about themselves to those and will be you take to you.
Do you,
you,
you like staring to deter dental?
Oh really good.
Why don't you go fucking spew that out in a bar and see if you get any fucking
pussy out of it.
Oh,
Bill.
Is that what it's all about?
All right.
Um,
I'm not going to look that up.
How long does it take for the earth?
Oh wait,
once a year.
It goes around the sun once a year,
doesn't it?
I think I remember that.
I think I got that right on a science test.
All right,
here we go.
How long does it take for the earth to go around the sun?
I know this fucking thing,
right?
It takes 24 hours for the thing to spin around and it takes a year for it to go
around.
It's visual.
They won't even answer me.
That's how dumb this question wasn't immediately goes to this visualization
visible is visualization shows how fast you're spitting around earth access.
I don't care if I can't feel it.
Why do I want to know it?
I don't give a shit.
MMM.
Fucking earth spinning on its axis is like eating iceberg lettuce with nothing
on it.
You know what I mean?
How does that taste?
Ah,
like I don't know nothing.
How the earth moves,
um,
publish,
this is how dumb this quite the answer is not even here.
Oh.
And Somehow Joe Rogan's on this.
Uh,
this is the thing that nobody really considers you know as much about.
I don't even want him worried that the fucking state I'm in right now.
Yeah.
Joe Rogan.
Joe Rogan reads people.
Okay.
That's the podcast you're looking for.
I suggest you go to the Joe Rogan experience.
Um,
I think the earth goes around the sun once a year.
I'm going to say once a year.
I feel like that last family member on family feud,
you know,
everybody can somehow scraped together for smart brothers,
sisters and maybe a random cousin Booney got you.
Try to get that fifth person,
you know,
it's,
it's the drop off is tremendous.
Okay.
So what do you do?
You always stick him there.
The last fucking one and they'll just nay nay a name us at type of dog,
but you know,
and that'd be like fuck it.
Uh,
a German shepherd,
German shepherd number one you guys want to play yet and then they go to the
next person and all and they fucking throw out a and the Daddy,
the daddy get all of way down.
Let the fifth guy named type of dog,
uh,
just fuck.
It's,
I can't even think of a dumb answer for type of dog.
That's too easy.
How many times as yours go around the sun?
How long does it take?
Three go around.
The Sun.
Uh,
Bill,
how long do you think it takes for the earth to go around the sun?
Um,
if you get this,
you guys will be playing for all the money.
If not the drink.
Water,
family has a chance to steal.
Uh,
what'd he say,
Bill?
Uh,
could you,
could you repeat the question?
Uh,
yeah.
No,
I can't.
I fucking said it four times.
All right.
How long does it take for the earth?
Just spin around the sun.
Um,
Richard,
please don't kiss me.
I'm going to say a year and a half.
Right.
Which is the dumbest fucking,
at least you know,
you know,
it's a solid fucking year.
You know,
it's a round number.
You're not going to say fucking it.
18 months.
Right.
And then,
but then all your other four family members as a staring daggers at,
you have to fucking stand there and start clapping and sake.
Good answer.
And in the 40 fucking years at that show's been on,
nobody has ever just stared at another family member
and be like,
what the f?
What the fuck did you just say?
Oh,
looked at a number of family and another family of mine said,
I told you we shouldn't have brought this dumb fuck.
That has never happened.
Well,
you know why bill?
Because it's a game shop when people are having fun,
something you don't know how to do.
MMM.
All right.
Hey,
you know,
I never,
I never like pre uh,
what do you call it,
promote a podcast coming up.
But I've got a podcast coming up on June 28th,
uh,
the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
And my guest will be none other than the one and only Dave Ilitch,
uh,
one of the great drummers in the world.
And uh,
also my drum teacher and he has a new,
um,
drum instructional website.
Awesome.
Fucking all of the shit that he's been showing me and everybody else,
everyone from my level all the way up to some of the best drummers in the world.
And uh,
he's going hard on this thing and uh,
he's going to show you guys all this shit that he's shown me.
So he's going to be coming on promoting that,
talking drums and all that type of stuff.
Just giving you guys a heads up.
Um,
because I think is a,
I think that whole educational thing is going to be fucking insane because I
know from first hand experience working with that guy over the last couple of
years is it has been a monumental shift in my playing and I'm just some fucking
comedian that likes playing drums.
Having said that,
having said that,
the amount of fucking people that showed me that,
that eight year old Asian girl playing good times,
bad times and absolutely destroyed.
Yeah.
That's one of my favorite videos of all time,
despite the fact I've been trying to play that song for 30 years.
Just the way she attacks the kit,
the whole thing.
Total rocks that comes out of the field hits the crash is coming out of the
chair.
Not only did she crush it,
that only did she hit the drums like a fucking monster.
Um,
she was unbelievably entertaining and it was kids like that.
They didn't have kids like that one.
I was a kid.
That's like some fucking youtube shit in the whole world,
showing you how to do stuff.
I don't know what,
Oh,
maybe that's just a prodigy,
but that,
but it was cousin kids,
you know,
gifted kids like that.
Why I shifted away from drums and ended up being a comedian because I would go
into the,
you know,
not every time,
but it felt like almost every time I would go into the local music store,
you know,
before fucking guitar center was just the one everybody went to.
I used to go to a place,
a Norfolk,
Connie,
music county music on route one in Dedham,
I believe is where I bought my drum kit way back in the day.
Back then when the child world was down there.
You know what I mean?
Uh,
I forget what else was down there before toys r us fucking took over everything
that was child world.
You went by leach mayors and fucking dead.
I'm all of that area right over there and a great Chinese restaurant,
the movie theater,
all of that shit that I remember as a kid that's now fucking long gone,
I assume.
Um,
I would go in there and they would always just be,
some kid would pick up something,
a guitar,
a fucking Xylophone,
a goddamn triangle,
and would not be just sitting down going,
Duh,
Duh.
No,
like,
you know,
saying something somebody else said,
they'd come in there and they would just start fucking playing and you could
tell that it was coming from them,
that or if they played something,
they would then add,
you know,
that you'd heard on the radio.
They then add something,
their own little thing to it.
And they just had ideas and they were creative and all that.
And I was musically,
I was those people outside the fucking,
uh,
Lilou at standing there,
you know,
putting my finger on top of the goddamn whatever the fuck you call it.
The pyramid.
Well that was depressing.
Jesus.
Bill,
wait a bum yourself up.
Um,
maybe let some of that vodka do shock a lot.
Uh,
I apologize for my growling stomach,
by the way.
So what happens when you're on a liquid diet?
Um,
and then I'm gonna just going to come back to the states here in about a week or
so,
and I'll be right back on the wagon.
See,
that's what I can do.
I can drink like an alcoholic and then just step off the fucking wagon,
the bus,
whatever you call it,
the party wagon,
and just start walking down the street like nothing happened.
Like a fucking Hitman,
right?
Like Barry,
like bill Hader and Barry just fucking walk away like nothing happened.
Anyway,
so let me read some of the,
uh,
advertising here for this week.
Okay.
All right.
Um,
I have this opening note.
The mushroom coffee dude ass that you don't say it tastes like mushrooms.
Other than that,
say anything.
Thanks.
Well,
that's fucking easy.
All right.
What would you think mushroom coffee doesn't taste like mushrooms.
I like mushrooms.
All right.
I actually had a fucking crepe today.
You have a day,
crepe crepe.
Wherever the fuck it is.
Okay.
Jumbo a fromage way.
Uh,
sorry.
I apologize.
Anybody remotely French.
Um,
alright.
Quip.
Sorry.
The truth is most of us are brushing our teeth wrong.
That's all I fucking stabbing yourself in the eye.
Not,
not for long enough and forget to change our brush on time.
That's because most brands focus on selling flashy gimmicks rather than better
brushing,
but not quip,
not these fucking guys.
So what makes quip so different you may not have asked?
Well,
for starters,
quip is an electric toothbrush.
That's a fraction of the cost of a bulk of bulkier brushes while still packing
just the right amount of vibrations to help clean your teeth,
your teeth,
ladies,
your teeth keep the vibration above your neck there.
Uh,
quips built in timer helps you clean for the dentist.
Recommended two minutes with guiding pulses that reminds you when it's time to
switch sides.
You don't even have to think anymore.
Next quip subscription plans are for your health,
not just convenience.
They deliver new brush heads on a dentist.
Recommended schedule every three months for just $5,
including free shipping worldwide on a dentist recommended schedule that they
paid the dentist probably to say sooner than you needed so they could sell barn
brush heads.
And that's how the world works.
And God dammit quip.
God bless you for fucking play in the game.
Quip also comes with a mount that's suctions right to your mirror and,
and sticks when you break up with that chick to use as a cover for a hygienic
travel,
wherever you take your teeth.
And finally,
everyone loves quip.
Everybody does.
Everybody loves it.
They were on Oprah's all list.
Oprah's all list.
Oh,
I need a paint my mansion.
Yeah,
I'll fucking see you got a good toothbrush named one of Time's best interview
invention.
Sorry.
Not An intervention.
And it's the first subscription electric toothbrush accepted by the American
dental association.
I got to tell you guys,
you know why I love it in an electric toothbrush.
Okay?
And this is some serious shit is I used to use the handheld ones.
I was like,
fuck electric toothbrushes.
Those things that bullshit.
And I ended up brushing my gum away along my fucking tooth line.
Ended up having,
you know,
a borderline,
uh,
ginger Vitus type of situation.
Not that,
what do they call it when you're a receding gum,
whatever the fuck you call that.
But what's great about these electric toothbrushes,
you don't have to move back and forth.
He just put it on there.
It does all the God damn work.
I stand by this despite all the negative shit I said,
I stand by this product.
Plus they're backed by a network of over 20,000 dentists and hygienists and
hundreds of thousands of happy brushes,
uh,
who use quip everyday.
Quipped uh oh.
I hope they do animals.
Quip starts at just $25.
And if he go to get
quip.com/bar right now,
you'll get your first refill pack for free with the quip electric toothbrush.
That's your first refill pack for
free@getquipdotcomgtquipfuckingstomach.com slash burr uh,
spelled,
I just did that.
I just spelled it out.
All right,
four sigmatic mushroom coffee man,
four sigmatic comes from Finland.
So you know,
it's good.
The F the fins defeated fucking the Russians in World War II.
You think they can make you a cup of coffee?
The same crunchy that gave us Santa Claus.
Angry birds.
Tuco Rask,
the goaltender for the Boston Bruins and mushroom coffee finish.
People consume more coffee per capital per capita than any other country.
Almost three times more than Americans.
Our right.
You know,
I've got to get all competitive.
Uh,
during World War II when there was a shortage of cottage,
the finish boiled mushrooms that grow on trees to make coffee.
Mushroom coffee has half the caffeine of regular coffee,
but it's twice as magical.
I don't know why I want to drink this stuff so bad,
uh,
easy on the gut,
less acidic and you don't get the jittery feeling you get from regular coffee.
It is a very smooth,
earthy flavor with some sweet notes in there for people who drink their coffee.
Black
called
adaptogenic.
What about for people who like their women black?
Well,
I enjoy the coffee a little more.
It gives you extra energy without more caffeine or sugar.
Perfect for creativity.
Hey man,
let's start.
A band helps when you need to get work done.
Think of it as supercharged instant coffee.
That sounds like some weed people talk about comes in easy to use and carry
single serving packets.
Just add water perfect for travel and when you,
when you're on the go,
cost us a dollar 50 per cup,
get 15% off your first purchase with code burn.
How much money would that be?
Everybody would be 15 cents in the dollar,
seven and a half on the 50 cents a,
I would say it's 22 and a half cents.
How the fuck do you do that?
Just go to four
coffee.com and try it for yourself.
All right.
Lastly,
but not leastly legal zoom.
It's time for a mid year.
Check in if you like everyone else,
you have a few things left on your to do list for 2018 and that's why legal zoom
is extending their friends and family discount to everyone right now.
That means for a limited time you get 10% off the things you keep putting off.
If you're a small business,
make your accountant happy by saving on your LLC,
Dba s Corp and more.
You can also save money wrapping up your last will or living trust before you go
on summer vacation.
Legal Zooms,
not a law firm,
but don't worry if legal questions or holding you up,
their network of independent attorneys can provide advice for your business and
your estate plans and more accomplish the things you need to get
done@legalzoom.com now and save 10% with legal zooms,
friends and family discount.
Just be sure who am I doing right now,
Dennis [inaudible] and added I'll put off,
that was some talking head.
Just be sure to enter Promo Code where and your referral box at checkout.
Oh,
it's going to drive me nuts.
This offer is only available for a limited time,
so hurry to legal zoom.com right now and use Promo Code [inaudible] for 10% off
legal zoom,
uh,
where life meets legal legal zoom.com.
Who the fuck was I just imitated it and yet one of those talk talking head
fucking people in one of those mindless,
oh,
it was one of those mindless fucking youtube shows.
Hi.
I forget what that show was called.
I have no idea.
Anyways,
people,
I think that's,
I think I did it.
I think I did 34 minutes.
All right.
Um,
we're going to do something interesting here.
Uh,
last week I went to the finals of Roland Garros,
Sarah and Patty.
And um,
for those of you who didn't get to watch it,
for those of you who've never been there alive,
I would like to close this Thursday afternoon just before Friday,
Monday pointing podcast with the sounds of the French Open as done by most Yogi
bear.
All right,
this is,
this is a point.
All right.
And this is um,
this is the two guys there.
I forget who.
So at this point,
alright,
here we go.
This is what it sounded like.
Serve to point.
All right.
Eh,
he,
yeah.
Oh Hey.
Yay.
That one,
that miss was the drop shot that fucked up the other guy.
All right,
I'll see you.
That's the,
that's the Thursday afternoon.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Have a great weekend.
You can enjoy the music and we've got another half hour of this of bullshit from
one that I did,
I don't know.
While ago.
Say
[inaudible] [inaudible] just want to eat
[inaudible] I don't want you wash.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's built birds.
The Monday morning podcasts for Monday,
June 14th,
2010 how the hell are you?
Are you good?
Did you have a good weekend?
Did you,
did you go down to that place with the thing I heard it was nice.
What's it nice?
It is nice.
Oh,
that's nice.
My son,
he had a recital this weekend and we were so nervous.
He was all flustered and more suburban.
Talk about shit that nobody cares about because frank was in the back with the
garden hose.
It froze up.
Oh,
by the way.
So we have to buy a new one of those.
So you know frank,
he goes on the Internet and he just starts researching all about those hose
hoses.
Yeah,
I can't,
I don't know.
Can you imagine just these sitting there at the end of a culdesac like that is
your fucking reality.
Rather than having a wine cellar,
I would have just have a secret room of fucking porn.
Okay.
With Kleenex for media.
The rub one out or just sit there crying at what became of my life.
I need,
can you go out and fix his bicycle?
Yeah.
No.
Why does he go climb a fucking tree?
Jesus Christ.
What did,
what did they do in the 18 hundreds?
You want to,
why the environment's so fucked up.
That's it right there buddy.
You just go when I go out and be a part of your kids' lives.
I don't,
that's why I told you I enjoyed condoms.
I didn't enjoy condoms.
I just didn't want to bust one in you without one on and now I did.
And now look at it.
Look at my face sweetheart.
Can't you see the misery?
Fuck him.
Well,
he half looks like Yo,
you go fix his fucking bike.
I'm not yelling.
I'm,
no,
I'm not.
All right,
so this is he a,
this is the podcast for this week.
Uh,
I got to admit,
this is like the 15th time I've tried to start it.
I don't know what's going on.
I'm in my bedroom,
it's fucking hot out because the sun shines on this part of my apartment during
this time of the day,
which is why usually I do this in the morning cause it's nice and cool.
And then the podcast is cool as opposed to now where it's stressed and a little
sweaty.
You know.
Speaking of sweat and you guys been watching the NBA finals,
have you been watching that shit?
This series?
I can't call it.
Lakers won the first game.
And I was like,
God,
Jesus Christ said,
look.
Unbelievable.
Then the Celtics come back and I still wasn't believing in him.
And I was like,
you know what?
Whoever wins game three,
they're going to win the series.
That's,
that's the pivotal fucking game.
And then the Lakers winning and I'm like,
I fuck,
we're done.
We're done.
And the Celtics win the next game to to,
yeah,
but what the fuck?
You know,
Lake as a when the next one,
cause that's how it's going.
And then ban the Celtics win again.
So there were up three to now logic would say,
well they going to do is win one out of two of the were evenly matched.
They've got to fucking do it.
But there's nothing logical about this series.
It's been,
uh,
it's been a war and I hope you guys have been watching because it has been a
classic and a people stepping up.
Not Too many bonehead mistakes,
although Laker fans might say a thing or two about Ron,
our test,
uh,
you know,
I could pick it,
some of my fucking players,
but you know,
it's been a classic goddamn series and usually,
usually I trashed the other team,
but I got nothing but respect for the Lakers.
I got another mister fucking great team and a,
I don't know what's going to happen.
I don't have to,
we're going to close it out the next game.
Will we win seven games with the Lakers win the next two?
I don't fucking know,
but I don't understand why they can't play a game on Saturday night.
What does the NBA afraid of?
You know we have t vose I don't,
I already fucking examined this shit.
I was just glad we swatted Pau Gasol a couple of times last night.
You know,
gave them a nice cold bucket of water to remind them of what a fucking bitch we
think he is now.
He's been playing great.
The whole God damn serious and Colby is,
is that guy is he is unfucking Gardall guys unguardable that third quarter yet
game five last night was unbelievable.
You see that fucking three pointer?
Was he like 15 feet behind the line and then would've killed is he threw it like
it looked like a shack foul shot except it went in,
it was like a frozen rope.
It was like barely any arc on the ball and there was still nothing but net.
It's like he'd fucking defies the laws of physics and there's a lot of people
out there as my voice cracks a little bit because I've been screaming for seven
successful shows at Caroline's this weekend.
I fucking raped the crowd this weekend.
I was in his own baby is having a great fucking time out that way.
But let's stick with the Lakers.
People keep fucking a
comparison saying,
you know he's the next Jordan a isn't.
This is how you know somebody isn't.
The next Jordan is there compared to Michael Jordan.
They say he's the next Jordan.
All right,
so they'll,
all that means is that you're playing at this is is he playing at the same level
as Michael?
Yes,
he is.
Well it if you shaved playing shape fucking levels.
Michael Jordan,
there are [inaudible] American.
What am I going to join?
I'll tell you why.
This is the fucking difference.
Michael Jordan changed the fucking game and I keep telling you sports cons this
and you don't fucking listen to me.
It's like you don't hear me.
You don't understand.
All right.
It's like,
ah,
what do I say?
It's like fucking Christopher Columbus.
Before that guy came along,
everybody thought the world was flat.
Then if you sale too far,
you'd go right off the edge of it,
but Columbus realize that it was round and there was people to be massacred on
the other side of the fucking globe.
He realized that and he became the first fucking guy to go over where they
didn't think while it maybe become,
some people say the vikings,
but whatever.
Let's just go with him getting the fucking credit.
All right.
Just so I can make my example work here now after he fucking does it,
if another guy comes along and he does it too,
he sailed at the level of Columbus,
but he didn't do some groundbreaking shit,
which is what Jordan did.
Jordan changed the fucking game.
Colby is just playing the game at the same level as,
as as as a Michael Jordan.
He's playing the game,
but he's not doing shit that I know that I haven't seen Michael already do.
You know?
So there you go.
That's what I'm saying.
The same way Dr
Jay Changed Basketball before Dr Jay came in the fucking league.
Everybody in the league look like basically half the league look like they,
they had my ability to play,
you know,
and then all of a sudden he comes along and the game gets elevated above the
fucking rim and he's doing shit in the Aba that nobody even thought about doing.
All right?
And then everybody sees him do it and it's like,
oh,
that's fucking possible.
And then they practice his fucking moves and now they're doing it and it becomes
a part of the fucking
game.
That's the difference.
Right?
And before fucking Jordan came along,
everyone's like,
you got to have a center.
You can't win without a big man.
And Jordan was the first guy to come along and says,
you know what?
Fuck you a big man and fuck your power forward and fuck the fact that I don't
even have a goddamn center and we do it.
He did have a center,
but the guy sucked Luc Longley or cart,
right?
He's like,
fuck it,
I,
you know what?
I don't need any of them.
I'm going to jump over all of them and fucking throw it down.
That's what I'm doing.
Stuck it to the next level.
Nobody dunked the way he fucking dunked until he did it.
All that shit.
You know what I'm saying?
So stop with this shit.
All right.
But I will tell you this without a doubt.
I think he's the most unbelievable fucking player,
uh,
that I've seen since Jordan,
but there's still a major gap.
Do you know what I mean?
You guys understand what I'm trying to say here.
It's like miles Davis Change fucking music.
Okay,
you buddy Billy down the street.
He plays the trumpet.
There's a difference.
He's going to play in it.
I'm not saying he's not good at playing it.
I'm not saying he can't play the songs that miles Davis made,
but he's not fucking miles Davis.
Who the fuck goes from sports to Miles Davis?
Is it any wonder this podcast is free?
Do you know?
My Web guy told me the other day,
I have over 250,000 downloads of my podcasts.
Not in a week.
I don't know exactly how much time or how many people.
Maybe that's what,
that's 14 listeners downloading it 58 fucking times each.
Does that come out to 250,000?
I don't know what it does,
but I was impressed and I was just thinking,
you know what?
What if I actually sold it for a buck?
A whack?
That'd be 250 grand,
right?
Government comes in,
man,
they knock it down to a buck 25.
Right?
Or maybe I can't get to keep a buck 40 of it,
but I got to fucking throw it on the crap table.
That is Wall Street.
Then they fucking come along.
They shake up the economy like an ant farm.
Now I'm down to 30 grand right there.
I still got 30 grand.
I can go out and go buy another Prius.
See how that works?
That's how America works.
Speaking of that Shit,
how was on the plane yesterday?
Okay.
And this fucking dude comes on,
uh,
you know,
with,
with what I described as game seven [inaudible]
one of these dudes where he walks down,
he doesn't smell,
and then the second he goes to put his luggage into the overhead compartment.
It's just like,
you have got to be fucking kidding me.
How did this guy make it?
Through security,
you know,
I can't bring water through security,
but he can bring this,
this fucking stench onto the plan.
Of course he fucking sits right behind me,
you know,
and I'm just like,
please just keep your fucking arms down.
Fortunately he did,
but it's,
those guys always get on the cross
country fucking flights.
So anyways,
there was this adorable,
uh,
woman next to me and uh,
she was from Australia,
had the little fucking a accent and all that type of
the shit.
So whatever.
Long story short,
we're taken off from JFK and one of the runways is shut down.
So it's taken for fucking ever right?
A couple people on the plane or in wheelchairs.
So that takes more time.
You know,
your proverbial fat fucks,
you know,
the whole deal.
So,
uh,
we take off like an hour and a half late.
That's just the whole fuck it.
Then by the time we land,
we land,
there's no gate.
And then we've got to sit there and wait to get towed in and the whole thing's
taken forever.
And she just does this shit where she just goes,
she says,
she goes,
is everything in America slow?
Yeah.
So I let it slide
and then the plane lands and we're all trying to see who won the Celtics and the
Lakers cause we all miss the fucking game.
Thank God ESPN showed the replay.
I caught the second half and it goes around the plane like wildfire fire,
you know the Celtics won,
Celtics won and this girl,
my mural was joking about how much people gives a shit and then this girl makes
comics something like,
you know,
Americans fucking Blah Blah Blah Blah.
And it's just like,
you know what?
I let it slide with the first fucking water,
but it's just really like,
they always talk about the ignorant American.
What kind of a fucking asshole comes here from another country and shits on the
country to somebody who is from this country.
When I was over in England,
I didn't walk around saying to English people how fucking awful their torsos
where I didn't do that.
They said,
I enjoy in England.
I'm like,
it's fucking great.
I can't believe I'm over here.
Royal Albert Hall,
it's beautiful.
I can't wait to come over here again.
Phenomenal fucking city.
I didn't say you food sucks.
You guys all have will.
Pharrel mushy.
Torsos I didn't say any of that shit.
I didn't talk about your teeth being fucked up.
I didn't talk about the weird inbred look because you've all been fucking each
other and the same goddamn strip of land for fucking thousands of years.
I didn't do that shit.
I was on my best behavior and here I am sitting next to this fucking clam is
everything in America's slow as opposed to what?
That beacon of speed that fucking Australia is
fucking people.
You know I went to Australia,
I was there for like three days.
I had a good time down there,
but you know,
I could have picked that place apart.
All the unemployed people just sitting in bars drinking.
Okay,
I fucking hate you know.
Same fucking cunts.
Same God damn just cunts.
That's all it is.
Everybody taking pot shots in American now.
That's what it is.
Because we've been on top and we've been exploiting their labor and I guess
maybe that's,
maybe we deserve a little bit of that shit.
But you know what?
Take a look in the fucking mirror Australia
or a woman from Australia.
The fuck I went there,
I was like,
wow.
Like I was going into the future.
Can I have a,
and then the fucking
sandwiches right in my hand before I even finish it.
I didn't find them to be overly fast over there either.
You wait,
you fucking wait.
You think it's not coming your way?
Our corporations are just ahead of the curve of where,
where your corporations are.
Are corporations have basically exploited every last legal way that they can
make more fucking money over here.
So now they're just stealing.
They're just stealing and they're cutting fucking staff members.
I actually had to wait like a half hour,
40 minutes to get my bag last night.
I think it was that Sunday thing.
Once again,
it's Sunday,
it's Sunday.
So we just have like a skeleton crew.
I don't know.
All I'm saying,
you know,
it's just bugging me.
It's like,
do you think I know that that shit isn't a little fucked up over here?
Do I need you to come over here?
I would never be in Australia and go like,
yeah,
Australians to another fucking Australian.
You know?
That's the type of shit I should felt like fucking stuffing her in a Goddamn
boogie board bag.
Boogie board bag.
Why did I pick that?
Because I saw that documentary of that stupid fuck from Australia who's put 200
pounds of fucking weed into a boogie board bag.
Right alliteration for you.
And then it goes to like Bali,
you know with even have cold medication,
they hang you by your balls in the public square and she gets life in prison.
Well that's what you get your dumb fuck.
That's what you get.
That's one of my thenot fuck Australia.
That's how it works.
You see?
And that's how it works right there.
This is a lot of people in Australia right now.
Maybe listen to this shit going.
You know,
I would never say that.
I would never do that if I went.
Yeah,
well one of you did.
So there you go.
Do you think Germany likes to be judged by Hitler alone?
They don't.
I bet there's a lot of sweethearts over in Germany.
Look at all those fucking fat jolly people during Oktoberfest,
running around,
dressed like they're in Hansel and Gretel,
you know,
shitting on each other or whatever weird fetishes they're into over there.
All right.
What Anna just fucking bugs me.
Anyways,
it was my,
it was my birthday this weekend.
I had a wonderful birthday.
I did a two to a sold out shows,
ads live.
The first show was sold out.
The second one was like 90% show sold out on a Thursday,
by the way.
And a afterwards I had a,
I had a slice of cake and a shot of whiskey and then another shot of whiskey.
And I'll tell you right now,
if you want to fucking hang over,
have a slice of birthday cake with a little bit of makers and uh,
you're going to be in business.
I was wronged me guys.
I really fucking abuse my body this weekend.
I really did.
And I blame you.
I blame,
I blame Joe to Rosa.
I just blame him.
It's just something about him.
You know,
he comes down,
he's got that stupid look on his face.
He already has a drink in his fucking,
and you know,
I don't want to drink with them,
but it's like,
I know he's,
I know he was adopted.
It's like,
what am I going to be yet another person who rejects this poor bastard.
That's the only reason why I drink.
Uh,
hang on a second.
I got to turn the fan up.
His fucking
all right.
Well,
how far are we into with 16 pathetic minutes into this podcast.
This is really been a lackluster podcast and I want to apologize.
I gotta tell you something guys.
I've started this thing like fucking six times already.
And uh,
I don't know,
I'm just,
I'm off this week.
Look at me.
I'm tacking,
I'm attacking my good friend Joe to Rosa.
You know,
it's a good friend of mine.
Loved the guy.
I respect him.
Even though when he sits down,
he looks,
I look at him and he looks like he has wheelchair legs
exam.
If you guys ever go out and you see Joe to Rosa sitting at the back of a club
just low and he sits down,
tell me,
it looks like his legs work,
you know,
every time he stands up you get like that excitement,
like you're seeing a miracle happening.
And I was allowed to see what I'm doing.
I'm,
I'm attacking Joe.
He's not even here to defend himself.
Ah,
Geez there.
Bill,
what are you doing?
Um,
it was my birthday this weekend and I got a lot of birthday,
well wishes on my birthday.
I want to thank everybody and then I also got a lot of a happy belated birthday
and uh,
I really don't,
I don't enjoy that.
All right.
If he didn't remember then fucking man up and just say,
yeah,
hey,
I forgot your birthday.
Sorry about that.
You know,
I was busy in my own life or,
you know,
maybe I don't give a fuck about you enough to remember it.
Just say that.
Say happy belated birthday.
I don't like that.
That's like Mary [inaudible]
taken all the fun out of it.
All right.
If you forgot my birthday,
do you think I actually remember that?
You didn't,
that you didn't fucking say happy birthday to me.
I was totally fine with whoever said happy birthday to me on my birthday and
then then you,
you got to come the next fucking day.
You know I'm still smiling.
I still got frosted on the side of my mouth.
I'm having a great God damn time and you've got to come up to me and wished me a
happy belated birthday to remind me that you didn't give a fuck enough to
fucking wish me happy birthday.
Right before you said that.
I didn't know.
I didn't know that you didn't wish me happy birthday.
Nor did I give a shit.
Actually looked up the lady cause I didn't know what it meant.
I know what belated birthday means.
You miss my birthday.
Sorry about that.
But belated is one of those,
those weird words in the English language that is used,
but it's only used then.
Do you,
do you ever hear belated at any other point during the year?
Jesus Christ?
Look at that fucking belated pizza,
son of a bitch.
You don't,
this is like a bad eighties bit was do the word polluted.
A bladed actually means later in relation to the proper time something should
have happened.
So like when I finally get,
get like married connect to connect with,
will I have a belated wedding?
You know,
if a woman carries a baby for fucking 10 months,
do they have belated giving birth cards?
Jesus,
I really should be wearing a fucking 80 sports coat right now with the sleeves
pulled up.
One of those Miami vice tee shirts underneath.
It's spiking up what's left in my hair,
you know,
coming up on stage to like some sort of rip off of the top gun theme.
Ben At the tank tank tank,
a Dan,
Dan and good evening ladies and gentlemen,
welcome to the funny bone.
Um,
I wish I did stand up in the 80s.
It just seems so much easier.
And you could,
you could like literally do coke and go on stage and nobody had a fucking
problem with it
could be absolutely out of your fucking mind.
And it was considered okay because it was the 80s.
I tell you what,
why don't we just actually jumped to the,
uh,
some of these segments that I have here.
Let's,
let's recommend some youtube videos for the week.
Okay.
And why don't we just settle in that this isn't going to be one of the good
podcasts.
Okay.
Why don't we just take the pressure off me and just realize that this isn't
going to be one of the good ones.
You know,
look at the Cohen brothers.
Every one of their movies.
Good.
Are they?
I don't fucking know.
I just had to pick somebody really successful.
I bet they made a bad one.
So whatever.
This is my fucking bad one.
Uh,
we're kind of like a,
what's his face
that I am night Shama lemme lemme Ding Dong,
right.
He made the sixth sense.
Everybody went crazy and then he made that movie where the guy takes the nap and
the lawnmower runs over him.
You know,
they can't all be gems.
People
look at ACDC,
my favorite band of all time,
they make like nine good records in a row and then they made,
they make a,
what was it?
Blow up your video.
They're that bad period.
Fly on the wall.
Who made who
blow up your video bump?
Edit,
edit.
Bet.
Bet at it.
Edit it.
Um,
yeah,
they,
you know what it is.
They got outside their wheelhouse.
They were actually trying to make a statement where it's like,
no,
you guys are ACDC.
You talk about balls,
the devil and fucking,
okay.
Don't start making social commentary about what's happening to the art of music
because it's going to go off the rails.
And that's exactly what happened.
Do I,
do I actually have the nerve to try to drag ACDC into this,
this tailspin of a podcast?
I apologize.
Fuck is wrong with me.
Okay,
let's,
let's recommend some youtube videos for the week.
Um,
videos.
All you got to see this one look up a 21 foot rule,
less talk,
more action.
And it's basically,
it's a psycho who,
um,
he's basically saying he's talking to gun people,
I guess this guy,
a knife soared guy and he's talking about the 21 foot rule that in the amount of
times going to take you to pull out a gun and I guess or whatever and squeeze
off a shot.
He's going to close the distance and stab your cardboard toe a torso.
So check that out.
21 foot rule and a less talk,
more action.
And then,
um,
there's a couple of good parody ones.
Does the 121 foot rule where it's a fat fuck doing the 21 foot rule,
21 foot rule from 121 feet and then there's the 21 foot rule lightsaber.
And by the way,
all of these,
if you don't want to search for these videos,
if you want them right at your fingertips,
if typing is too much of a bother because you're too busy,
all you have to do is go to the MM podcast.com and uh,
all the videos will be up there and a right,
right,
right at the tip of your fingers.
You can select them,
you can watch them.
And uh,
and that's what you can do.
And I could actually come up maybe with something else.
Good to say about the page if I wasn't so fucking off this week.
I'm just off people.
All right.
I'm fucking,
we know it built.
We know it sucks.
Okay,
we got it.
All right.
Here's another one to watch.
Uh,
watch one crazy red sox fan and it's basically about a red sox fan who goes to a
Yankees game and start serving clam chowder outside the stadium during a red sox
Yankees game,
but only two red sox fans.
And if you,
if you just want to see what you look like when you're drunk at the game,
just watch this video because it's pretty much equally embarrassing on both
sides.
The level of fucking morons,
although I have to say,
uh,
a bunch of Boston CIC show their tits on it,
but then again,
that's because they're happy women don't show their tits when they're mad at
you.
So I guess none of the Yankee skanks showed their tits on it,
but definitely,
definitely check that shit out.
But uh,
oh,
here's one I should have talked about when I was talking about the Celtics
Lakers.
I was talking last week about why do you,
why do we care so much about sports?
You know,
why was I on the plane flying across the country?
Absolutely livid that I wasn't going to be able to watch the game,
but part of me was relieved that when I got off the plane,
I was just going to hear the results and know one way or the other,
you know what I mean?
Just get fucking one right to the back of the head rather than sitting there
slowly at her.
No,
slowly getting something,
something that slowly fucking happens.
That's funny,
right?
If you're not fucked,
I'm about,
you know what?
I am fucking,
if I fucking say one more thing that's not funny on his Goddamn podcast,
I'm going to fucking erase it.
25 minutes in,
which would be an unprecedented move.
Okay.
I bail out of these things like a fucking test pilot.
Three minutes in,
five minutes in six months,
even 10 minutes in.
I've never been less funny for fucking 25 minutes that I'm going to scrap this
God damn project.
This is pathetic.
This is like that fucking plane that took off like a helicopter and kept killing
people and was so fucked up.
Even Dick Cheney finally said,
you know what?
Fuck it.
It's not worth it,
but we spent $4 billion.
Yeah,
but they keep fucking going in the ground like a God damn lawn dart.
That's what's happened in this week.
Fucking sweat my ass off my bedroom.
That's what I'm saying.
I'm going to blame them.
I blame the climate.
All right.
I had a little temper tantrum.
Let's talk about sports here.
Why we care.
This is what you know.
I was asking last week,
why?
Why do people give a fuck about sports?
Why do you care to this level?
Why do you cheer on these guys?
Half of whom would blow you off if you saw him.
You know Mike,
you seen maybe seen her that fucking Douche bag.
He doesn't even smile during a game.
He think he's going to give you a fucking autograph as even in the League
anymore.
Why don't you bring up vital blue bill?
There's a nice uptodate fucking reference.
Okay,
why we care.
This guy is a great,
great theory.
Thank God.
I'm going to be really somebody else's words.
I hope he has something funny to say.
All right.
First off,
I want to say I love the podcast,
not after this one,
sweetheart.
Um,
you're doing God's work anyway.
I might not be able to explain why all sports fans care about their respective
teams.
But I thought I'd tell you why I care and see if you or anyone else can relate.
There are two main reasons why I not only watch sports,
but actually allow events that are usually happing happening nowhere near me
involving a bunch of people I never have,
nor will I ever meet affect my mood in either a positive or a negative way.
First off is the sheer unpredictability,
unpredictability of it.
Okay,
no worries.
Okay.
So,
uh,
so you were surprised when you found out the kid in sixth sense was already dead
or when Kevin Spacey started walking straight in the end of you have the usual
suspects.
We're,
neither of those were worth a shit compared to a guy catching a pass with his
helmet while being dropped on his fucking head in the last minute of a fucking
Superbowl to keep the winning drive alive.
What a great fucking point.
That is.
A great game.
And a major sport.
Football,
basketball,
baseball,
and I'll even throw in hockey as a courtesy to me.
Oh,
thank you,
dude.
Thank you for,
uh,
thank you for actually thinking about me.
Um,
is okay watching a great game and either one of those major sports is a,
is for me better than the best movie or TV show.
It's the ultimate fucking drama.
And as far as I'm concerned,
oh,
as far as I'm concerned,
second,
Jesus Christ,
I can't fucking read.
The font is too short.
Second,
following teams and players,
over time,
you can see some inspiring shit.
I love this guy talks right when you think he's going to be intelligent,
he starts cursing.
This sounds like my act.
You can see some inspiring shit.
This guy's really a motivational fucking dickhead.
Um,
as a Yankee fan,
I watch Derek Jeter go from some skinny kid I'd never heard of,
to arguably the greatest shortstop of the modern era.
I watched Andy Pettitte go from an okay rookie to a fucking Jesus freak who did
steroids.
Sorry,
that was me.
Um,
go from and,
okay.
Rookie to a guy who has an outside Charlotte at the hall of fame.
Why?
Because he admitted that he fucking did.
I like how he just came out and admitted that he cheated and that makes it okay.
Is that all the bankers had to do?
Yeah.
Sorry.
We actually took all the money and now old people are eating dog food so they
have a chance of being in the hall of fame of bankers.
Is that what you're suggesting,
sir?
I really should start peddling this because I actually agree with what he's
saying here,
so now you have to go back tiny typing on a smaller scale.
I've seen a guy like Phil Hughes go from rookie,
a rookie who look overrated a couple of years ago to a guy who's tearing up the
League right now,
I'm sure for all the faggy Laker fans seeing Pau Gasol finally step,
finally step up and show some testicles instead of allowing the cells to punk
him again is inspiring on some level a watching players and teams overcome these
struggles.
Make me thinks that if these guys have it in themselves to go from just
believing they can achieve great things to actually doing it.
I can too.
Maybe it sounds corny or like it came out of a Disney movie,
but that's why I give us fuck about sports,
you know?
And I mean,
how can you argue that shit?
I mean,
how many times do you watch your movie and within the first 10 minutes you can
figure out where it's going.
You know,
there's the dude,
he's a fucking loser.
There's the fucking cool guy.
He's the shit.
He's treating the guy like shit.
He's got the hot girlfriend.
The lose of guys actually ended the toy if you need to finish it.
Chee,
how's that one going to end?
Let me guess.
The fucking good looking girl finally realizes that her dick dickhead boyfriend
who treats her like shit from the beginning of the movie is actually a dickhead.
Boyfriend dumps him and then she actually gets with this guy the fucking loser.
How many times did they make that God damn movie?
You know how many fucking movies?
All of a sudden the uh,
you know,
vampires,
they just keep movies making movies about vampires.
Don't they are TV shows where all of a sudden vampires are sexy.
Now.
Is that what's going on?
See that?
That was a bad example.
I thought I got the podcast back on on fucking track.
That was a terrible example.
I went from being able to predict how a movie is going to go to talking about
trends and movies,
that they're making a bunch of fucking vampire movies.
What I should be saying is that they're predictable.
Actually.
They are predictable.
All right?
Some cool new kid with a gray face is going to move to school and everyone's
going to look like,
let's say the guy looks like he's fucking dead,
but there's something about them that everybody kind of likes and all the girls
pussies are going to get wet because there's something about his extra long
fucking canines.
Number six and number 11 to all you fucking dental douche bags out there,
you know?
Then he fucking bites their neck,
sucks their blood out.
Then they become fucking maniacs,
but it takes three times and somehow that fucking whore it,
you know is actually going to have a regular boyfriend,
but she can't resist his gray phase Douche bag with the giant fucking teeth.
She's going to bang them one other time.
She bangs.
One more time.
She's going to become a vampire and her boyfriend who should just say,
fuck that bitch.
If she wants to hang out with that big tooth junky cont let her become a
vampire.
I don't give a fuck.
For some reason he saw pussy whipped.
He's got to go save her and the only way to save her is to drive a stake through
that fucking assholes,
heart and g.
Do you think he's going to do it?
Do you think he's somehow going to save her in the end?
Now,
can you do that with sports?
What is predictable in sports other than people are going to get absolutely
fucking hammered and that they're going to be out of shape and a,
that they're going to love their team when they're good and that they're going
to hate them when they're bad.
But as far as the outcome of the game,
you have no fucking idea.
You know deep.
Don't you think right now as a Celtics fan that I want to sit here and I want to
start talking shit and say that it's a wrap.
You know what?
It's never a Rep.
Look at the Bruins
up three games to none against the fucking Philadelphia flyers.
Go on and we lose,
by the way,
congratulations to the Chicago Blackhawks and my condolences to the flyer fans
and I'm dead serious when I say it.
A lot of people think that I fucking hate Philly because of that rant when in
reality I was,
you know,
just doing a show and I was trying to piss people off from Philly.
All right.
Um,
that was a great thing to see,
but I got to admit,
man,
that was the worst winning of a championship I think I've ever seen.
Just for the,
just for those of you who don't watch hockey,
Patrick Kane in overtime and overtime goal to win the Stanley Cup.
He shoots the puck.
And this is really funny because people always see who hate hockey on to watch
it on TV.
Always say they can't see the puck.
This fucking guy is shot the puck and it somehow it went into the net.
It was from,
from the side.
He was almost parallel with the goal,
the goal line.
And he shot it in,
in a disappeared into the side of the net and no one could knew where the puck
was except for Patrick Kane who shot at.
So he starts celebrating running down with his hands in the air,
doing the jazz hands,
you know,
and all this fucking teammates are kind of like a,
well,
Patrick's freaking out,
dead silence in the spectrum or wherever the fuck you guys play.
The Wacovia center dead fucking silence.
And then they have,
the reps had to go and do a review of it and five minutes later they like,
oh yeah,
yeah,
you won the Stanley Cup.
And then they had to regroup and get happy again.
I was so,
it was such a fucking buzz kill.
But a congratulations to the Black Hawks and uh,
hey maple leaf fans.
Let me ask you something.
Were you rooting for the flyers?
I bet you were because now you guys are the saddest fucking sacks in the league.
Isn't that right away?
Does it?
1967 is that the last time you guys want it?
And I believe it is,
but if you want it the last time in 1967 than that and then you would actually
be be tied with the expansion six.
Anybody in the expansion six who didn't win it and that will be the California
seals where think went on to become the Cleveland Barons,
but they folded so they tapped out.
Saint Louis Blues had never won it out of the expansion six.
Neither have the La Kings,
Minnesota north stars.
One is the Dallas Stars in 1999
penguins won it last year.
They wanted two times 91 and 92 look at this.
Why do I have this meaningless fucking information in my head?
Flyers.
One at 74 75
is that six right there.
One,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six.
There you go.
Let me look this up.
Toronto.
Why don't I stop and just look this up.
God knows I'm not being fucking funny this week.
Toronto Maple leafs.
That's actually a city I want to do a fucking stand up in,
but they never seem to fucking pony up any goddamn money.
All right.
1966 Stanley Cup final was the best to seven series between the Montreal
Canadiens,
Toronto Maple leafs.
Montreal may believes when the Stanley Cup and they'd never fucking went another
one.
So there you go.
So now it's a threeway fucking tie
for the longest futility in hockey.
Toronto Maple leafs,
the Los Angeles kings in wherever the fuck else I said,
cause I can't remember.
And the St Louis Blues
and I'm praying all you guys don't win because the next person on that fucking
list is then I believe going to be the Bruins in 1970 and less Vancouver came in
and like 70.
Is that what happened?
Calgary flames capitals.
They all came in the early seventies right?
Isn't this interesting?
I don't think it is.
Jesus Christ.
Let's go back.
Let's go.
Let's,
let's go to some questions.
Maybe this will help me,
um,
questions for the week.
You know what?
I'm literally looking at the clock this week,
the way I do when I have a bad set and I'm looking down at my watch.
Like,
how many more minutes do I have to do?
How many more?
God Damn minutes.
All right.
Question a bill.
If you had enough money to quit,
stand up and had the balls to give up your dream of becoming Ernest Borgnine,
where would you live in?
What would you do with your time?
All right,
I have enough money and I can quit.
Stand up and I don't want to become an actor.
All right.
Uh,
where would I live in?
What would I do with my time?
I would live,
I think I'd live back east and I would live on a big piece of land where I could
grow my own food.
I'd get a pistol.
I get all the sports fucking channels.
I think I would live in a,
I dunno,
I'd want to live right outside of New York City,
one of those places.
Terry town or an uh,
Jersey above the wash,
George Washington bridge,
all those fucking ritzy places,
but out out in the sticks a little bit.
I'd lived there and I enjoy the four seasons to get a dog,
a couple of horses I never ride.
To me,
that's one of my goals in life.
I want to get a couple of horses in a,
and I want them never to be written in their lives.
You know,
after I found out what you have to do to make a fucking horse want to be
written,
you got to break them
the same way they break those fucking,
those people who work at hardware stores in slash terrorists.
Dan in Guantanamo Bay,
you know,
you got to do that to a fucking horse.
And even then the horse,
she never quite,
cause I,
I noticed a couple,
the one or two times I've ridden a horse,
they still kind of are rebellious.
They do shit.
Like a friend of mine actually used to work with horses and said when you go to
put the saddle on him,
you got to tug it real.
You've got to tug the belt underneath.
You gotta Tuck it real tight.
Cause what they'll do is they'll take a big inhale.
All right?
And then when you go to in a new,
tie it on and then when you go to get on top of it,
they exhale on the saddle slides down.
You fall off the fucking horse.
I mean,
right.
If I,
if I ever had a horse and it never did that shit right there,
I would look into its big brown,
beautiful horse size and I would be like,
you,
you don't want to be written.
Do you?
You know whether that's it.
It's fucking over fucking over.
I'm not writing anymore.
All right,
go ahead.
Go run around in this fenced in area and don't fucking complain.
I'm fenced in to
this areas I can't go to.
Why can't just cross borders you everything I've fucked up that is with like
countries and that type of shit.
I'll just where you're born,
you're just all of a sudden on that team,
you know,
like why we're not allowed to just wander,
why can't I just walk to Brazil
like the old days and fucking go in and wash some dishes at a saloon,
make a little bit of money,
and then jump on a fucking stage coach and right out of town to some bullshit,
right?
Just fucking head down to Brazil and chill out down that you can't fucking do it
anymore.
God have all these goddamn identifications,
microchips and all this shit.
I've got to worry about roving bands of fucking gorilla terrorists
arrested abroad.
You guys ever see that fucking show arrested abroad makes you like you never
want to travel again?
I have to tell you,
even even this last time when I went,
when I went out of the country and I went to England,
Ireland and Scotland,
uh,
not only ridiculously white,
not only do they all speak English,
but I'm actually have ancestry in all those parts of the country.
I still couldn't quite relax until I got back,
uh,
on my own turf.
You know,
I saw a spiral.
I saw somebody with dirty toes and flip flops.
I was like,
America,
I'm back.
I'm fucking back.
Can you do that in in a,
no,
you can't even even in like a like how does that work over in Europe when you,
you know those dirty American college kids all of a sudden decide to get on a
fucking,
I'm
that guy.
They become dirty because I want to do it that you get on a train,
just go around Europe.
How does that work?
Do you have to show your passport,
your papers?
Please do you have to do that?
Or You guys so advanced in the new world order that you're all on the same
fucking currency and you just have one DMV making you a fucking driver's license
with a barcode in the back.
Have you seen that?
You guys seen the new creepy commercial
way where I don't even know what the fuck's going on.
They have a baby in the middle.
It and the Al Volleys.
This electronic shit like examining every inch of the bay and that IBM
commercial,
the way they're selling microchipping the entire world with,
um,
become a smarter planet,
become a smarter planet.
Right?
Who's gonna argue with that?
No one wants to know,
wants to become a dumber planet.
Watch those commercials and read between the lines and see what the fuck they're
setting you up for.
They're already getting you comfortable with all the,
the,
this,
this robotic laser shit.
Looking at your,
your naked little baby,
they're going to fucking just like a goddamn dog.
They're going to stick a microchip right in the back of fucking Barcode,
right on that soft part of his fucking I,
that's where they're going to stay.
This third eye soft part of his skull to where they're going to bury them.
Microchip.
Right.
I give it one more generation and the only job that there's going to be as a
fucking human being other than wiping the ass of the Illuminati is to be the guy
who oils the fucking robots.
Other than that,
the rest of us,
we're going down.
We're all getting processed.
That's my message on this happy fucking horrific car crash of a fucking podcast.
Um,
next question.
So that's why I do,
I would live back east and I,
I would like to live on a big piece of property and I'd like to learn how to
grow my own food.
Um,
even if I wasn't into that conspiracy theory,
um,
type of shit.
I just,
uh,
there's just something about it.
I,
I think you should know how to live off the land.
I think you should know how to survive,
um,
in the wild.
I just think that stuff,
I think you should know how to defend yourself.
All of this stuff,
I don't know how to do,
you know,
and I know how to defend myself as you put me in a headlock,
I put you in a headlock and then we both,
shit,
they're tugging on each other going quit.
You quit,
you quit first.
Like that's all I know how to do,
you know,
sit on your chest and fucking punch you.
That's,
I know how to do that.
If you're my little brother,
I know how to beat you up.
Um,
I don't know how to survive in the wild.
I was actually on the,
uh,
the Internet the other day and I was trying to learn how to hot wire a car and
pick a lock just in case just in case this shit happens.
And I'm that guy running around with cargo pants and a backpack like that
fucking show.
They have you seen that show after the apocalypse and the guy goes through the
garbage and he somehow finds
you know,
stuff to eat and how to start a fire.
I don't know how to do any of that shit.
I want to learn how to do that shit so I don't take the coward way up and just
kill myself.
You know,
a lot of people have that as a plan.
That's it.
Backup PLO up.
Shit goes down.
I'll just kill myself,
you know?
Next.
Next problem.
All right,
next question.
Here we go.
Dear Bill,
I'm 19 and I do stand up in New York City.
Well at least I did until I ran out of money,
paying for all the open mics and transportation of Troy show yawning here of
trying to get a job to pay for what I love doing.
Sounds like a plan.
Right?
Absolutely.
Sounds like a plan.
But of course the shit will eventually hit the fan.
Uh,
in about a month and a half,
my mom is going to move back to New England and I'm definitely not going back
because one,
that shit sucks.
And to New York is the best place to do stand up every day.
My mom and my older brother give me shit for every little thing every day.
My,
uh,
what,
sorry,
my fucking,
I just jumped the line.
I'm trying to get a job,
but I look like a hippie.
So that shit ain't easy.
No Way.
Every day my mom and older brother give me shit for every little thing I do.
I'm trying to get a job,
but I look like a hippie.
So that shit ain't easy.
Um,
now for the part that leaves me make,
making,
uh,
leads me looking like,
like a pussy.
I feel like no matter what I do,
I'm wasting time.
I should do stand up every night and my carefree attitudes does nothing but piss
off the stressed out bastards in my house.
If you were in this situation,
what would you do?
A well,
you didn't give me enough of your situation to fully tell you.
Um,
I don't know how old you are.
Oh,
19.
Yeah.
Uh,
what do I do?
I would get a fucking job.
That's what I would do.
I would get a job that would allow me to stay in the tristate area.
I would continue to do stand up down there.
That's what I would do if you don't want to move to Boston,
but,
um,
you know,
if you want it to move to Boston,
I mean,
that's where I started.
I can't really comment on the scene.
The scene was great when a,
when I was up there and I had a day job and I did spots at night,
came to work sleepy or whatever,
and I got myself to the point,
I just saved up a ton of money.
Um,
I could give you this advice.
Whatever you do,
don't get a fucking credit card and get yourself into some ridiculous debt
because that is the,
uh,
that's the modern day slavery is the loaning of money at interest.
And you need to avoid that at all fucking costs.
So what I would do,
get a reliable car.
All this shit requires money,
but I would not go out and buy a brand new fucking car,
get a job,
and get all this fucking debt to quote unquote build up your credit.
I wouldn't do any of that shit.
All right?
I would keep myself,
um,
I wouldn't be in a relationship,
you know,
I wouldn't,
I would keep it.
Um,
I keep it real light.
Travel light is what I would say travel like,
dude,
you're 19 years old.
You ought to be able to sleep on the sidewalk.
All right?
Your body is still brand new.
It's brand fucking new.
You don't have any aches or pains.
If you want to stay there,
you just stay there,
find a fucking job,
whatever you gotta do,
just get a Goddamn job out there.
And then I would continue on and then,
uh,
just think positive,
think positive in his bat.
And no matter how bad it fucking gets,
just think this is just a funny chapter in a,
in a,
in a book that I'll write some day or a funny story to tell if I'm sitting on
the couch on Conan one day,
just look at it that way.
Don't listen to the negative fucks around you and uh,
just keep going.
That's what I would do.
If you want to stay in the New York area and do stand up,
then that's exactly what the fuck I would do.
Do that.
That is my advice to you.
Good luck to you,
sir.
And I hope it all works out for you.
And if by the time you make it,
I've already made it and then have a fucking brutal drug habit,
uh,
helped me out,
trust me,
tossed me and opening gig.
I'll open for you.
Um,
all right.
This is one of the last things.
There's gonna be a short podcast this week.
I apologize.
I just don't fucking have it this week.
I really don't.
I got a million things on my fucking mind.
I got a bunch of bills I have to pay.
I got all this shit.
I'm running around,
hey,
you know,
it's fucked up.
They,
I got I a,
I thought it was gonna be doing Letterman again next week.
Uh,
I got bumped again.
So at least that stress is taken off is kind of cool though,
because the set has been ready since May.
So,
um,
rather than the panic that I usually have,
usually when they asked me to do Letterman,
uh,
they call me up,
they go,
what do you got?
You've got five minutes ready.
And as always,
I lie and I go,
yeah,
I got five minutes clean material.
Um,
and then I frantically try to put it together and uh,
you know,
I stressful like fucking 14 days before I finally start to get it.
I feel like I have it and then it always ends up going well,
but there's an unbelievable amount of stress.
But the thing is,
is I already went through that bullshit in April,
getting ready for the beginning of May.
And then,
um,
you know,
then it went away and then,
uh,
started to build up again and all of a sudden June,
I'm ready to go on the today.
Boom,
you're out.
You fucking out.
So,
so I'm ready to go.
I don't know what the point of that fucking story was.
Okay.
You know what,
I just am I allowed to take a week off people?
Am I,
how about this?
We just,
um,
we just got the final copy of my new special is ready.
We,
we uh,
just locked the master or whatever they say.
Technically it's ready to go.
I got extras and one of the extras actually is the Monday morning podcast,
which would have been a great thing to bring up if,
uh,
yeah,
if this was actually a decent podcast,
but one of the extras is we,
I filmed one of my podcasts,
um,
another extras is some people heckling me in a club,
a couple episodes of that
and uh,
whatever.
The rest of it,
you'll find out when you buy the thing.
And considering this thing is free.
I'm letting you guys know right now when I get an actual release date for this,
uh,
for the podcast,
I'm going to be coming at you guys hard and heavy with the guilt.
Okay?
And if you think you're only going to be required to buy one DVD,
I got news for Ya.
I got,
I'm,
I'm going more than that.
All right?
I'm not going to say how many I think you should buy,
but it's more than one and it's less than three.
But I'm not going to say what that number.
Behavior.
All right,
let's read the last thing here.
Overrated for this week.
Overrated sprint.
Customer service.
I swear to God,
these people are just there to Piss you off bill.
It's like,
no matter what you say,
they have some textbook comeback to make you seem like an asshole of funny.
Is that a,
what?
Do they explain the phone and you don't get it.
So now you're blaming them.
Actually know what you're saying.
Um,
I have been with sprint for years now and I'm always bitching to them about this
shitty phones.
But can you blame me?
Either the screen,
either the screen breaks or the fucking thing doesn't charge.
Like two days ago I went and yet again to get my phone looked at because when I
plugged in the charger,
the phone wouldn't charge.
So I bring the phone up and the charger,
I bring the phone and the charger up into the store and the Douche bag behind
the counter says the charger port in the phone is bad.
We will order you a new phone,
come back in two days and it'll be here.
It'll be here for you.
Keep in mind,
uh,
they looked at both the phone and charger.
So I say,
that's fine with me.
I'm ordering a phone.
Takes some time,
two days,
no,
no big deal.
Two days later I pick up the phone and bring it home to find out the fucking
thing.
Doesn't charge some sitting here thinking,
what the fuck did they order me a new what?
The,
what the fuck did they order me a new phone for?
So I go back to the sprint store and I very calmly explained that the charger
was the problem the whole time.
Like I had said since the beginning.
So they go back and fuck around the things some more and this comes back to me
and tells me that I was right.
Um,
and here's where I get pissed.
She tells me that I need to buy the new charger myself because apparently a full
insurance doesn't cover accessories.
I swear to God,
I never would have,
I would never hit a woman,
but this bitch got me so angry.
Um,
I explained that,
that uh,
they were the ones,
they were the ones who diagnosed,
diagnosed the fucking problem,
not me.
They're the ones who ordered a new phone when I didn't even need one.
Plus I had to wait two days to find out all this to find all that shit out and
they still charge me $40 for the fucking thing.
No discount or anything.
Sorry.
Just had to vent.
Yeah.
That's one of those deals where you have to,
um,
you have to stop talking to the person at the counter.
The first thing you have to do is you got to keep your temper in check.
I did a whole segment on this about a year ago about the magic of the word
unacceptable in whatever wisdom I learned was fleeting because I've gone right
back to flipping out and screaming at people.
And I can tell you from personal experience that that is not,
it's not,
does not get you the desired results.
So what you should have done was say that
I need to talk to somebody above you.
I understand you don't make these rules.
You just keep complimenting the person.
And he just keeps saying it's unacceptable,
unacceptable.
Eventually that you're going to get to the highest person in the store and what
they're going to do is tell you that you then have to jump through a couple of
fucking hoops,
email people,
something involving the Internet and they're all just hoping you're going to tap
out.
But if you never fucking tap out,
you're going to get what you have coming to you.
That's just what they do.
That's just how it works now.
And,
uh,
you know,
I don't know what to tell you.
I don't even know what to say.
God knows it won't be anything funny.
This fucking piece of shit of a fucking podcast,
this fucking podcast.
Where was it?
Was was a car.
Here's some questions for you this week of this podcast was a car.
What would it be
if it was a comedian?
Who would it be?
If it was a president?
Go to the [inaudible] podcast people,
the [inaudible] podcast.com.
Go to that page.
We'll have the questions up there and you can fucking send in your answers and
I'll read them next week.
If you want to trash me,
go right ahead.
I fucking deserved
that.
You know what?
This is the,
this is the first
time of podcast is really seem like work.
Usually I'm in here,
I'm having a good time.
Maybe I'm,
I'm fucking jet jetlagged.
What if I just ran out of funny?
You know,
they always say that you've got to worry about that shit as a comedian.
You just dry up.
Maybe I'm drying up.
I turned 42 years old and that's it.
That was the magic number.
First 18 years of his career,
man,
a tay.
The gay fucking just steadily improved.
He just kept getting better and better and better.
And then he hit 42 and I dunno what happened.
He started regressing.
First thing he did,
he started doing the podcast in the afternoon.
It was hot.
He started sweating.
Cooking is fucking brain,
you know,
just fucking all went downhill from there.
See right there.
I thought I was going to go on some sort of a riff and it just fucking ended.
I got nothing.
Why would I think after 55 minutes of mental torture
dead,
all of a sudden I was just going to pull this fucking gem out of my ass.
Is that what I thought was going to happen?
It didn't.
I got fucking news for you.
My brain would just started thinking of the oil spill.
Like I was going to riff on that.
I got nothing to say about it cause I'm fucking watched a second of it because
there's nothing I can do about it.
All right.
Put a picture up when when you clogged the fucking hole.
By the way,
if they ever going to be able to clean that up,
are we so in trouble that,
that you realize that they actually listened to Kevin Costner.
Kevin Costner actually got a meeting with the government.
That's how dumb I am.
I don't even know what branch of the government.
He went to Washington and he met with the government,
you know,
whatever the fuck he did.
He went to one of those buildings that's painted white and as pillars out in the
front and he went in there and there was fucking five old people sitting there
in suits and he,
you know,
he did the usual,
I didn't come here as an actor.
I came here as a blah,
blah,
blah.
He has got some side company
that I guess vacuums oil off the top of the water.
How did even get that meeting?
What are they?
Well,
he was in waterworld.
I mean there's water right there.
Shit.
But the,
fuck me,
he and he did fucking play odd.
John F.
Kennedy.
Actually,
no sir.
He didn't.
He played the guy investigating it while he was in contact with the president.
There you go,
right there.
He fought in the civil war.
He fucking played baseball.
He built a Goddamn stadium.
What more does this guy have to fucking do to get a God damn meeting with us?
He finger bag meg Ryan in the back of that Limo.
What else did he do?
I can't.
I can't remember any of his.
I know.
I'm fucking all these up.
He was fucking with the guy from the breakfast club when they went skydive and
Fandango.
Hey,
remember that one kid who had that part in the movie and Fandango who just slept
in the back of the car?
The entire fucking movie.
I had my,
my part in date night was one level above that,
that actor and Fandango called me and the guy from weekend at Bernie's called me
to see how did you get eight lines?
Dude,
you're,
you're blowing up.
You fucking blowing up.
So anyways,
fucking,
uh,
Kevin Costner,
who liked Jack Nicholson is gonna take forever to go bald.
You know,
I don't know what those guys dump on their fucking heads,
but they,
they,
they really,
they stave it off.
They really stave it off.
I,
on the other hand,
I'm not using any of that shit.
I'm just letting it fucking happen.
And then what I'm going to do is in 10 years,
I figured the fact that they can grow a fucking colon outside of the human body,
if they can fucking do that in,
in 10 in it,
and then take out the old one and stick the new one in.
Like he just got a new exhaust system.
There's no fucking way.
They're not going to have a cure for this shit in 10 fucking years.
I'll just fucking pop a pill and she'll just start growing back like magic,
like fucking magic.
I learned that.
I learned that the other day when I was watching one of those shows for,
you know,
it,
it's not a,
it's not out to pay at your actual fucking hair.
Right.
And they got that 50 year old guy running his hands through his,
his Jay Leno had a hair now and he's going,
you know I wish I did this 10 years ago and it's like dude,
no you,
no you don't.
No you don't.
If you go back and look at what hair plugs look like 10 years ago,
sir,
you're going to say I'm really glad I waited.
It's like people will go in and get their tattoos removed and then they just
have that permanent Indian sunburn because they fuck it up because it's new.
Just wait a few years,
wait a few years.
It's all going to be great if you,
if that's,
that's my advice for you.
If you can wait.
I had a buddy of mine who did crystal meth and a bunch of fucked up drugs and he
dried out his joints and had to get like hip replacement surgery at like 36 and
he's needed it for like six years and the doctor says just wait,
just wait.
Just wait.
Cause when I was younger,
if you got hip replacement church surgery,
you are fucked unless you got it at like 60 or 70.
Because it only lasted for like 10 years.
And people used to die in their sixties John Wayne,
all of them fucking rump roast hanging out of the fucking your anus.
He just collapsed one day.
Just fuck.
I was just rump roast and Geritol pills under the undigested Geritol pills.
That's,
that's all.
You just died to that and everybody dropped in there fucking sixties.
But whatever I'm going,
I'm trying to say is you're fucking,
you hip only lasted for 10 years and then then you were in a wheelchair.
Like what's his face?
Earl Campbell.
Earl Campbell now was in a wheelchair,
but,
uh,
my buddy has needed it for like five,
six,
seven years in,
in a s five,
six,
seven years ago,
the said of stuttering again said,
uh,
that he needed this hip replacement surgery.
And he's just told him if he can wait,
if he could deal with the pain that,
uh,
the advancements that they were having,
he would be so much better.
And he waited.
And I hadn't seen the guy in a minute.
One of those friends we showed up,
you only went to a fucking hockey game or something and he had handicap plates
and I couldn't understand why he's walking normally said,
oh,
I had,
I had hip replacement surgery and I was like,
when he said like six months ago and he's fucking walking around all normal,
get the fuck outta here.
He goes,
yeah.
And he explained the whole thing how now they used to like just cut your whole
leg open almost from my hip down to your knee and just remove your entire hip
and like,
I dunno,
like half your fucking femur
now.
I don't know what they do.
I Dunno what they do,
but it's working people.
Is this interesting me explaining fucking hip surgery.
I don't even know what I'm talking about.
Maybe that will work with the oil spill
you want.
The big deal is is I like how Kevin Costner has actually has a side business
that's so fucking smart because if you listen to this fucking podcast,
shouldn't I really have a side business?
Should I have something to fall back on?
Ah,
fuck.
That's it.
All right.
Go Fuck Yourself.
I'm sorry.
Go ahead.
Have a good week.
Don't judge me.
I'll be back next week.
Okay.
M and M and a couple of bad albums.
I heard his new ones fucking unbelievable.
All right.
See
[inaudible]
[inaudible].
Sure.